Phoenix's mayor and police chief are
apologizing to a family planning to file
a 10 million dollar lawsuit over an
incident caught on video you know shows
officers cursing and pointing guns
threatening to shoot after responding to
a report of shoplifting
Jeff PJ's is outside the Phoenix Police
Department which has been involved in
use of force controversies before Jeff
how does the family's account differ
from what police are saying
well good morning police say that this
is an incident that went beyond
shoplifting that the father was not
complying with their commands several
times now the videos they don't show the
beginning of this confrontation but the
family says that police went way too far
over an accident they want the officers
and Phoenix PD held accountable I'm not
able to sleep I keep having pictures of
guns pointed at my face
Trevon Ames and his pregnant fiancee
Aisha Harper say they are still shaken
three weeks after their encounter with
Phoenix police I was in June allowed me
mentally and physically me and my
treasure cellphone video from May 27th
shows officers with their guns drawn
verbally threatening them repeatedly in
front of their two young children you
can see an officer kick Ames in the back
of the leg while he is handcuffed it
hurts a man's probably if you can't
protect your family you hear your
daughter screaming and you can't do
nothing about it
police were responding to a shoplifting
incident the parents four year old
daughter took a doll from a dollar store
nearby but police say Draven Ames also
stole a pair of underwear was driving
with a suspended license and refused
their commands to pull over several
times all of which he denies reverend
jared muffin is a civil rights activist
in phoenix i don't care if they stole
every damn doll from the dollar store
what you see on that tape you cannot
justify over the weekend Phoenix's
police chief Jerry Williams apologized
to Ames and Harper this incident is not
representative of the majority of
Phoenix police officers who serve this
city but earlier this year a report
commissioned by
Williams found that 2018 was Phoenix PDS
most violent year on record there were
44 officer-involved shootings the most
in the country and more than double the
previous year we spoke to Williams in
February there are some people who think
well our Phoenix Police trigger-happy so
there are some people who think a lot of
things my agency is unafraid of the
truth if there's something we can learn
let's learn it let's fix it
that report prompted significant changes
including de-escalation courses and
implicit bias training but the family
says it hasn't worked them officers is
still basically working and I feel like
that should be just as for us and what
we've been through the officers have
been placed on desk duty until the
internal investigation is completed the
mayor of Phoenix Kate Gallego is called
the situation terrifying terrifying and
she called the video beyond upsetting
and she has announced new protocols for
officers that includes every officer
having a body camera on them by August
Anthony right action being taken there
in Phoenix Jeff thank you very much